Narrator:
TONIGHT ON "SHARK TANK"...
[ LAUGHTER ]
'TIS THE SEASON TO BE JOLLY.
NO CASH FLOW
FOR YOU!
IN THE TANK, ENTREPRENEURS SEEK
AN INVESTMENT TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESSES.
WHOA!
IT'S COLD OUT THERE, PEOPLE.
HELP US SPREAD THE LOVE.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
[ VOCALIZES ]
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
$300,000 FOR 20%.
I'LL MAKE THE SAME OFFER
EXACTLY.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAND
THE CONTROL OF YOUR BUSINESS
OVER TO ANYONE.
I'M REALLY GREAT
TO WORK WITH.
I TALK WITH MY ENTREPRENEURS
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
I WALKED IN HERE
KNOWING YOU WERE GOING TO
BEAT ME UP ON THE PRICE.
SANTA DOESN'T LIKE THAT.
...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
YOU HAVE
NO MARKET SHARES.
OUR CUSTOMERS
LOVE THIS.
WHO CARES?!
WE'RE TAPPING INTO
THE HUMAN NEED TO CONNECT.
YOU COME IN HERE AND SAY,
"WE'RE UNIQUE. WE'RE SPECIAL."
WE ARE.
THE CHEAPEST WORDS
EVER SPOKEN.
I-I'M GONNA
PROVE YOU WRONG.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2-BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A HIGH-TECH WAY
TO DECORATE FOR THE HOLIDAYS.
♪♪
Boyink:
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M BRAD BOYINK
FROM FERRYSBURG, MICHIGAN.
MY COMPANY IS GeekMyTree.
I'M SEEKING $225,000
FOR 25% EQUITY.
I'M MODERNIZING
CHRISTMAS-TREE LIGHTING.
EVERY YEAR, WE TRY TO UNTANGLE
THAT BUNDLE OF LIGHTS.
WE HOPE THEY WORK.
WE WRAP THEM AROUND AND AROUND
THE CHRISTMAS TREE,
AND YET, AFTER A COUPLE DAYS,
THE TREE MOSTLY GOES UNNOTICED.
YOUR TREE DESERVES BETTER,
AND THAT'S WHY I CREATED
ANIMATED GLOW BALLS.
WITH THE ANIMATED GLOW BALLS,
WE HAVE BROUGHT THE FUN
AND EXCITEMENT
OF THE OUTDOOR LIGHT SHOW
INSIDE
TO THE FAMILY CHRISTMAS TREE.
ANIMATED GLOW BALLS HAVE
ALL KINDS OF PATTERNS AVAILABLE.
WE HAVE "FILL HER UP."
WE HAVE "BACK TO SPRING."
ONE OF MY FAVORITES --
"COLOR RAIN."
"SPARKLING GREEN,"
LIKE MONEY FOR MR. WONDERFUL.
WE HAVE OVER 118 DIFFERENT
PATTERNS AVAILABLE FOR THIS.
AND IF YOU THINK THE PATTERNS
ARE COOL, WITH YOUR HELP,
THE NEXT STEP IS TO OFFER FULL
MUSICAL SEQUENCES LIKE THIS.
[ TCHAIKOVSKY'S "THE
NUTCRACKER'S" TREPAK PLAYS ]
PRETTY COOL, HUH?
UNLIKE OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT JUST BLINK THE LIGHTS
RANDOMLY TO MUSIC,
THESE ARE
PROFESSIONALLY SYNCHRONIZED.
HUH.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY
TO HELP ME LIGHT UP THE HOLIDAYS
IN A WHOLE NEW WAY?
SO,
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST?
IT'S $299 AND $399 RIGHT NOW.
WHOA!
ACTUALLY,
I CAN PASS THESE OUT
SO YOU CAN SEE THE QUALITY
AND HOW WE ARE DOING IT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT YOU GET FOR THAT IS,
YOU GET THE CONTROLLER.
YOU GET
16 PATTERNS BUILT IN.
THE MOBILE APP,
WHICH ALLOWS YOU
TO BUY ADDITIONAL PATTERNS.
THERE'S L.E.D. STRINGS
ON THE MARKET NOW
THAT ARE
MATERIALLY CHEAPER.
YES.
LIKE, A LOT CHEAPER.
LIKE, A LOT.
WHAT CLEARLY
SETS GeekMyTree APART
FROM ANY OTHER SYSTEM
OUT THERE --
IS YOU HAVE TO BE RICH
TO HAVE THEM.
POOR KEVIN --
NEVER BE ABLE TO BUY ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M JUST STUNNED
BY THE PRICE.
WHY ARE YOU STUNNED
BY THE PRICE?
BECAUSE IT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
YOU'D HAVE TO BE RICH.
IT'S A TON OF MONEY!
YOU PAID MORE THAN THAT
FOR A BOTTLE OF WINE LAST NIGHT!
THE CHILDREN DON'T GET ANY GIFTS
THAT YEAR.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THAT'S ONE SET OF LIGHTS
WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE, JUST ONE?
THIS IS OUR STARTER KIT
WITH OUR EXPANSION.
HOW MUCH
IS AN EXPANSION KIT?
UH, $200.
WHOA!
BRAD, BABY!
BRAD --
I CAN BUY A TREE,
OR I CAN GET A HOUSE!
BRAD, DO YOU SEE ANY PROBLEM
WITH A FAMILY PAYING OVER $500
FOR LIGHTS
ON A TREE?
IT'S NOT
FOR EVERY FAMILY.
NO KIDDING 'CAUSE MOST OF THEM
AREN'T GONNA SEE SANTA.
THEY'RE GONNA SEE A BAILIFF
WHEN THEY GO TO DEBTOR'S PRISON.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S RIDICULOUSLY
EXPENSIVE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Boyink: MR. WONDERFUL,
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
THAT IT IS EXPENSIVE.
I WAS ONLY ABLE TO DO A LIMITED
PRODUCTION RUN FOR THIS SEASON.
SO, WHEN --
HOW MANY DID YOU RUN,
BRAD?
WE'RE DOING 2,000 UNITS.
IF YOU ACTUALLY RUN
A LARGER VOLUME,
WHAT CAN YOU
GET THE PRICE DOWN TO?
UH, I KNOW IF WE CAN GET IT OVER
10,000 UNITS...
YEAH.
...WE CAN DROP OUR PRICE
BY 20%.
IF WE CAN GET
OVER 50,000 UNITS...
IT'S STILL
A HIGH PRICE.
O'Leary:
IT'S STILL A HIGH PRICE.
...WE CAN GET DOWN
ANOTHER 30%.
HOW MANY OF THESE
HAVE YOU SOLD?
ALMOST CLOSE
TO 300 RIGHT NOW.
300?
Corcoran: AND HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS CRAZY IDEA?
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL, YOU KNOW THOSE PEOPLE THAT
DO THOSE MEGA CHRISTMAS SHOWS?
YES.
YEAH,
I WAS ONE OF 'EM.
UM,
I ACTUALLY DID ONE
THAT WAS THE SECOND LARGEST
IN THE COUNTRY.
I DID 14 HOUSES
ALL SYNCHRONIZED TOGETHER.
HUH.
OVER 70,000 PEOPLE SHOWED UP
TO SEE THAT SHOW.
WOW.
HOW EXCITING.
IT WAS CRAZY!
YOU'RE A GREAT NEIGHBOR.
WOW.
BRAD,
YOU'RE SANTA CLAUS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BRAD,
YOU'RE STANDING THERE
SELLING A $500 STRING
OF CHRISTMAS LIGHTS.
THE ONLY ONE WHO WOULD SPEND
$500 ON THIS TREE
IS SOMEBODY RICH LIKE ROBERT,
WHO LIVES IN
A 20-BEDROOM MANSION ON A CLIFF.
SO I'M VERY OUT.
♪♪
Herjavec: BRAD?
YES?
I DON'T SEE HOW YOU'RE GONNA GET
TO A LARGER MARKET.
KEEP DOING IT.
HAVE FUN. I'M OUT.
♪♪
Cuban: OKAY, SO, BRAD,
I THINK IT'S COOL,
BUT I JUST DON'T SEE IT
GETTING TO BE A BIG BUSINESS.
MERRY CHRISTMAS,
BUT I'M OUT.
FOR CHRISTMAS,
PEOPLE WILL SPEND MONEY,
AND THEY LIKE TO DECORATE
AND ALL OF THAT.
IF IT WAS SOMETHING CHEAP,
UNDER $50,
THEN, I THINK, AS A NOVELTY,
PEOPLE WOULD BUY INTO IT,
BUT WHEN
IT'S REALLY EXPENSIVE,
I FEEL LIKE
THAT'S REALLY SOMETHING
NOT FOR
THE INDOOR USE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I WALKED IN HERE
KNOWING YOU WERE GOING TO
BEAT ME UP ON THE PRICE.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS IS,
YOU CAME IN, IT WAS INTRIGUING,
AND THEN YOU HIT US
WITH THE PRICE,
AND IT CHOKED
EVERYBODY.
THERE'S NO WAY TO GIVE YOU
A QUARTER -- $225,000 FOR 25%.
THE PRICE IS KILLING ME
BECAUSE IT'S SO EXPENSIVE,
BUT I STILL
WANT IT.
Greiner: SO,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WELL, YOU KNOW,
I'LL DO THIS DEAL WITH YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU $225,000 FOR 50%,
AS PARTNERS.
OH.
WHAT?
YOU CAN DO BETTER.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE HIM MORE
OR LESS, I DON'T CARE.
HO, HO, HO.
I'M TELLING YOU
WHAT I WOULD DO.
Corcoran:
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
I LOVE IT,
AND I'M GONNA BUY IT ANYWAY
BECAUSE MY WIFE MAKES ME
PUT UP A TREE EVERY YEAR,
AND I HAVE TO STRING THE LIGHTS,
AND IT MAKES ME FRIGGIN' CRAZY.
YOU DON'T DO IT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I MAKE
MY SON DO IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT I STILL
HAVE TO SUPERVISE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO,
BRAD?
UM...
♪♪
CAN WE DO 40%?
NO,
I WANT TO BE A 50/50 PARTNER.
THAT'S IT.
I THINK THIS STUFF'S
TOO EXPENSIVE. I SAID
THAT FROM THE BEGINNING.
I'M CHOKING.
♪♪
BRAD, I CARE.
I BET ON ENTREPRENEURS.
THEY COME TO ME WITH IDEAS.
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
I OWN HALF THE COMPANY.
50% -- I CARE.
♪♪
YOU GOT
TO DECIDE.
♪♪
LET'S DO THIS.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
MERRY CHRISTMAS,
KIDS!
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
THE PLATFORM WILL DO IT.
WE GOT TO SELL THIS THING.
THEY DON'T BELONG TOGETHER.
IT'S LIKE A BAD GUY
WITH AN ULTIMATE GOOD GUY.
[ LAUGHS ]
MAYBE THEY'LL BALANCE
EACH OTHER OUT, BARBARA.
NO WAY.
THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
O'Leary:
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU
TO ALL OF YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, BRAD.
THANK YOU, BRAD.
Boyink: I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE 50%
BECAUSE I KNOW IN THE LONG RUN,
HE'S GONNA HELP ME BRING THIS
INTO EVERY AMERICAN'S HOUSEHOLD.
IT'S GONNA BE
A MR. WONDERFUL CHRISTMAS.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A FESTIVE AND FUN WAY
TO KEEP WARM IN CHILLY WEATHER.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DAVID STANKUNAS.
I'M THE FOUNDER AND CREATOR
OF...
THE BEARD HEAD!
AND I'M SEEKING $250,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 25% OF MY COMPANY.
THE BEARD HEAD IS THE NEXT
ESSENTIAL WINTER ACCESSORY
SET TO TAKE THIS COUNTRY
BY STORM.
WHETHER YOU'RE SKIING
DOWN THE SNOWY SWISS ALPS
OR CHEERING IN THE STANDS
OF A CHAMPIONSHIP GAME,
THE BEARD HEAD
HAS GOT YOU COVERED.
NOW, WEATHER IS CRAZY --
RECORD BLIZZARDS ALL ACROSS THE
EAST COAST, THE POLAR VORTEX.
IT'S COLD OUT THERE, PEOPLE.
QUESTION IS,
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE A LUSH,
FULL BEARD OF THEIR OWN,
HOW CAN YOU KEEP
YOUR PRECIOUS FACE WARM?
I'VE GOT THE ANSWER FOR YOU.
[ FINGERS SNAP ]
BEARD HEAD.
[ LAUGHS ]
BEARD HEAD IS A HAT OR BEANIE
WITH A HAND-KNIT,
DETACHABLE BEARD FACE MASK.
THEY'RE SOFT, WARM, COMFORTABLE,
AND WITH MORE THAN 200
DIFFERENT DESIGNS
RANGING FROM OUR OUTRAGEOUS
BARBARIAN ROADIE BEARD HEAD,
A BUSHY BIKER BEARD HEAD,
TO OUR PINT-SIZE
KIDS' COLLECTION,
WE HAVE SOMETHING
FOR PRACTICALLY EVERYONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ GREINER SIGHS ]
WANT TO CELEBRATE THE HOLIDAYS
IN STYLE?
CHECK OUT
OUR CLASSIC SANTA BEARD HEAD,
AND YOU'LL BE SPREADING
CHRISTMAS CHEER ALL NIGHT LONG.
GOING TO A FOOTBALL
OR BASKETBALL GAME?
TAKE ONE OF OUR
36 DIFFERENT COLOR COMBINATIONS
OF TAILGATE BEARD HEAD
TO SHOW OFF YOUR TEAM SPIRIT.
IT'S COOL.
NOW, I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE ALL THINKING.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU CAN'T WAIT
TO TRY ONE OF THESE ON.
[ LAUGHS ]
I CAN'T WAIT
TO TRY IT ON, DAVID.
BUT FIRST,
I HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION
I MUSTACHE YOU.
WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
WILL JOIN ME
AND TAKE BEARD HEAD TO CREATE
THE PERFECT STORM OF SUCCESS?
♪♪
SAMPLE TIME NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
♪♪
HERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU,
DAVID.
THIS ONE
IS GONNA BE FOR YOU.
Greiner:
THIS ONE? OH, MY.
GET THAT ONE.
HOW DO YOU...
Stankunas:
AND, BARBARA.
Corcoran: THANK YOU.
Greiner:
UH, VELCRO.
ALL THE BEARDS
ARE DETACHABLE.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK GOD.
[ LAUGHING ]
HO, HO,
HO, HO, HO!
[ LAUGHS ]
NO CASH FLOW
FOR YOU!
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: OH!
Cuban:
VERY NICE.
DAVID,
I LOVE IT.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA,
BUT LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
SURE.
HAVEN'T I SEEN THIS BEFORE?
WE DO HAVE COMPETITORS,
YEAH.
OKAY.
LOTS OF THEM.
SO, WHY ARE YOU DIFFERENT
THAN THE OTHER ONES?
WELL, FOR ONE,
I WANT TO JUST POINT OUT
WE CAME OUT JANUARY 2009.
WE DIDN'T START SEEING COPYCATS
AND IMITATORS
UNTIL ABOUT 12 OR 18 MONTHS
AFTER THAT.
BUT THEY DO EXIST.
YOU'RE THE FIRST
TO DO THIS?
YES.
BUT THERE'S NO WAY
TO PROTECT IT?
IT IS NOT UTILITY-PATENTABLE.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR NUMBERS,
DAVID.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE'VE SOLD TO DATE 250,000 BEARD
HEADS -- $5 MILLION IN SALES.
THIS YEAR?
NO, NO, NO --
TOTAL, SINCE WE BEGAN.
SO, THEY SELL
FOR 20 BUCKS APIECE, TYPICALLY?
TYPICALLY,
$25 TO $30.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD
IN THE LAST YEAR?
SALES LAST YEAR -- $936,000,
WHICH WAS AN ANOMALY FOR US.
WE HAD A DOWN YEAR.
THE PRIOR YEAR TO THAT WAS
$1.3 MILLION AND $1 MILLION.
BUT, ALSO,
MAYBE IT MEANS IT'S SLOWING.
Stankunas: IT COULD.
SANTA DOESN'T LIKE THAT.
LAST YEAR WAS A TOUGH YEAR
FOR US BECAUSE...
WE WERE IN
AN EXPENSIVE LEGAL BATTLE.
LET ME EXPLAIN
WHAT HAPPENED.
SO, OUR COMPETITOR CLAIMED
THAT THEY HAD A DESIGN PATENT
AND ONE OF OUR STYLES
INFRINGED ON THAT DESIGN.
Herjavec: AND WHAT WAS
THE END RESULT?
EVERYONE WALKED AWAY.
BUT HOW MUCH
DID YOU SPEND IN LEGAL FEES
TO WALK AWAY
IN THE END?
$150,000.
SO, $25 TO $35
YOU SELL IT FOR.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
AVERAGE COST IS ABOUT $4.50,
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE RANGE
'CAUSE WE HAVE
SUCH A WIDE RANGE OF PRODUCTS.
RIGHT.
THAT ONE COST $9.50 TO MAKE.
PROFIT MARGINS ARE BETWEEN 25%
AND 35% NET INCOME --
NET-INCOME MARGIN,
AFTER COMPENSATION, EVERYTHING,
SO WE HAVE VERY,
VERY STRONG MARGINS.
SO, YOU'RE MAKING $250,000,
$350,000 A YEAR?
YES.
Herjavec:
HOW DO YOU SELL IT, DAVID?
WHAT RETAILERS?
WELL, WE'RE IN ABOUT
400 TO 500 STORES,
BRICK-AND-MORTAR STORES
THIS SEASON.
O'Leary:
SO, IT'S SEASONAL?
IT GOES IN FOR THE FALL
RIGHT THROUGH THE SPRING?
IT'S -- WELL, I THINK
IT'S MOSTLY HOLIDAYS.
DAVID, I TOOK A FLYER
MANY SEASONS AGO
ON THE TIPSY ELVES GUYS, LEARNED
A LOT ABOUT THAT BUSINESS.
AND MADE A TON OF MONEY.
COME ON, ROBERT.
WE DID MAKE A TON OF MONEY.
WE SIGNED A LICENSING DEAL
WITH COLLEGES, BY THE WAY.
RIGHT.
THERE'S ONLY FOUR COMPANIES
YOU NEED TO GO TO
TO GET
TO ALL THE COLLEGES.
YEP.
BUT...
THE SALES
WERE ALWAYS LIKE THIS.
WELL, WE HAD $1 MILLION,
$1.3 MILLION,
WE HAD THE DOWN YEAR, AND THEN
THIS YEAR, WE'RE GOING BACK UP.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
100% FINANCED
THROUGH PROFITS
FROM DAY ONE.
THE FIRST FOUR YEARS
OF THIS BUSINESS --
RAN IT COMPLETELY
OUT OF MY BEDROOM APARTMENT.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT EVENTUALLY, WE OUTGREW THAT,
AND I HAD TO GET A REAL OFFICE.
AND NOW WE HAVE A WAREHOUSE,
AND WE'RE REALLY MOVING PRODUCT.
WE'RE AT A POINT NOW
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY SCALE IT.
I THINK YOU HAVE ALL THE REASONS
TO BUY INTO THIS BUSINESS.
YOU'VE GOT
ALL THE MAGIC INGREDIENTS.
YOU HAVE GREAT MARGINS,
YOU'RE MAKING $250,000 A YEAR,
AND YOU'RE SELF-FINANCED.
YEP.
GOOD FOR YOU,
AND YOU'RE A SMART GUY.
THANK YOU.
BUT HERE'S THE RUB.
I REALLY HAVE TO LOVE A PRODUCT,
AND I DON'T GET THIS.
I'M OUT.
♪♪
Cuban: DAVID, LOOK,
I THINK YOU'RE GRINDING,
YOU'RE HUSTLING,
YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB WITH IT.
UM, FOR THIS TO BE REALLY
WORTHWHILE AS AN INVESTMENT,
THERE'S GOT TO BE AN ANGLE
TO GET IT TO SCALE
TO BE A $10-, $20-MILLION
BUSINESS, AND I DON'T SEE THAT.
I'M OUT.
♪♪
SOMETIMES WITH PRODUCTS,
THEY'RE A GENIUS IDEA.
YEAH.
REALLY CUTE.
THEY HIT
THE MARKET.
THEY BLOW UP.
MM-HMM.
THEY HAVE A HUGE RISE,
BUT YOU PEAK,
AND THEN IT STARTS TO SLOW DOWN
BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S HAD IT
AND THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR THE NEXT FUNNY THING
TO TALK ABOUT
OR TO DO.
RIGHT, I MEAN, WE'VE BEEN AROUND
FOR A LITTLE WHILE,
SO, CERTAINLY, THE PEOPLE THAT
KIND OF FREQUENT THE TYPE OF,
YOU KNOW, WEBSITES
THAT WE MIGHT ADVERTISE TO
MIGHT HAVE SEEN US
AT THIS POINT,
BUT I THINK, ONE, WE HAVE 5% OF
OUR BUSINESS COMING FROM KIDS,
AND LOOK AT THESE KIDS.
REALLY CUTE.
THEY'RE ADORABLE,
RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
IS THAT NEW FOR YOU?
IT'S -- IT'S NOT NEW.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT...
WE HAVEN'T REALLY GONE INTO
SO MUCH.
I'M A ONE-MAN SHOW,
AND SOMETIMES I HAVE TO FOCUS
ON OTHER THINGS.
IT'S BASICALLY ON ME.
IT IS A REALLY CUTE IDEA,
BUT THEY'RE A FAD.
RIGHT.
SO, FOR ME,
I'M NOT GOING TO INVEST,
BUT WITH YOUR MIND,
I THINK YOU COULD COME UP WITH
THAT NEXT BEST THING
BECAUSE YOU DID IT PHENOMENALLY
ONE TIME.
YEAH.
SO, I'M OUT,
BUT...
I'LL BE WATCHING YOU.
HEY,
I-I'M GONNA PROVE YOU WRONG,
AND I'M GLAD
YOU'RE GONNA BE WATCHING.
I MEAN, THAT'S REALLY
WHY WE'RE TRYING TO GET --
WHY I WANT TO BE
IN THE TAILGATE,
IN THE SPORTS-FAN MARKET,
BECAUSE THIS
IS A CONSISTENT MARKET, RIGHT?
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
ONE MULTIBILLION A YEAR --
SO, DAVID, I HEAR YOU
ON THE TAILGATE THING.
OKAY.
I LOOK AT IT -- SORT OF MY MODEL
FOR "SHARK TANK" DEALS IS,
I WANT TO AT LEAST SEE A PATH
TO A POTENTIAL OF FIVE "X"
ON MY INVESTMENT,
BUT TO GET FIVE "X," TAILGATE
HAS TO TRIPLE YOUR BUSINESS.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET
TO $7 MILLION IN SALES.
I MEAN,
THAT'S...
I'M NOT SAYING
YOU WON'T DO IT. I-I JUST --
RIGHT.
IT'S A TOUGH ROAD,
I UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, IT'S JUST
I'M NOT EXCITED ENOUGH.
FAIR ENOUGH.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU,
DAVID.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THEN THERE WAS ONE SHARK WHO'S
INVOLVED IN DRUNK ELF SWEATERS.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
YOUR PERFECT PARTNER, ROBERT.
WE'VE DONE VERY WELL
WITH THEM.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING,
ROBERT?
YEAH, YOU KNOW,
WHEN THE TIPSY ELVES CAME ON,
THEY WERE DOING $600,000 A YEAR,
WHICH I FOUND AMAZING.
IN UGLY
CHRISTMAS SWEATERS,
WE'LL PROBABLY DO $15 MILLION
THIS YEAR.
WOW.
YEAH, SO,
WE'VE HAD THAT TRAJECTORY.
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE.
YOU SPIKED.
YOU HAD THAT,
BUT YOU FLATLINED.
YOU KNOW,
SALES DON'T LIE.
I WONDER IF YOUR GROWTH IS BEING
ABSORBED BY OTHER PEOPLE.
RIGHT.
LIKE THE OTHER BEARD GUYS
OR SOMEBODY ELSE.
SO...
RIGHT.
...I WONDER IF YOU'RE NOT
RUNNING FAST ENOUGH.
WELL,
SAY WE NEED TO MOVE FASTER.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
WE GET A SHARK,
WE CAN MOVE FASTER.
YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN IT
WITH TIPSY ELVES.
YOU'VE SEEN WHAT THEY CAN DO
WITH A SIMILAR TYPE OF CONCEPT.
AND WE CAN DO
THE SAME THING.
♪♪
ROBERT,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
♪♪
DAVID, I'M SORRY.
I DON'T SEE IT.
♪♪
I'M OUT.
MM.
ALL RIGHT, WELL...
♪♪
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD LUCK.
UH-HUH.
GOING FROM $300,000
TO $1.3 MILLION --
OBVIOUSLY,
WE HAVE OUR DOWN YEAR --
I MEAN, THAT'S NOT BAD GROWTH,
AND THEY WERE REALLY FOCUSED
ON WHAT WAS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
INSTEAD OF THE PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE.
♪♪
I'M WOMBI.
AND I'M JOHN.
AND WE'RE
FROM BOSTON, MASSACHUSETTS.
I THINK THIS SHOULD BE
MORE OF A PIRATE RED.
JOHN AND I MET 10 YEARS AGO
IN COLLEGE,
STUDYING SHIP DESIGN,
NAVAL ARCHITECTURE,
AND MARINE ENGINEERING.
WE RECONNECTED
AT HARVARD BUSINESS SCHOOL
A FEW YEARS LATER
AND DECIDED TO PURSUE
A BUSINESS IDEA TOGETHER.
I THINK WE GOT IT.
LET'S GET IT IN THE COMPUTER.
WE USE OUR BACKGROUND
IN SHIP DESIGN
TO CREATE A UNIQUE TWIST
TO AN EXISTING PRODUCT.
WE'RE USING
THE SAME SOFTWARE,
THE SAME 3-D THINKING
THAT CAN HELP PEOPLE
CREATE MEANINGFUL CONNECTIONS.
THIS BUSINESS
MEANS EVERYTHING.
NEITHER OF US TOOK A JOB
COMING OUT OF SCHOOL.
WE'RE UNDER
A LOT OF STUDENT LOANS.
WE'VE PRETTY MUCH INVESTED ALL
OF OUR MONEY INTO THIS BUSINESS.
WE COULD'VE TAKEN LUCRATIVE JOBS
AFTER GRADUATING HARVARD,
BUT WE BELIEVE SO STRONGLY
IN OUR IDEA
THAT THIS IS ALL WE WANT
TO FOCUS ON.
WE NEED A SHARK
TO HELP US GROW THE BUSINESS,
OPEN MORE RETAIL OUTLETS, AND
REALLY GET OUR BRAND OUT THERE.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO TOUCH
PEOPLE'S LIVES WITH OUR DESIGNS,
AND A SHARK CAN
MAKE THAT POSSIBLE IN A BIG WAY.
♪♪
HI.
I'M JOHN,
AND THIS IS MY PARTNER, WOMBI,
AND WE'RE
THE CREATORS OF LOVEPOP.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO OFFER YOU 10% OF OUR COMPANY
FOR $300,000.
REMEMBER THAT TIME
WHEN YOU WERE IN THE DRUGSTORE
AND YOU WERE SEARCHING
FOR A BIRTHDAY CARD?
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
THAT RACK
OF THOUGHTLESS,
UNINSPIRED CARDS,
DOING THAT MULTIPLE-CHOICE
SELECTION PROCESS,
AND YOU END UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT'S...
OKAY.
DON'T SETTLE ANYMORE.
COME TO LOVEPOP,
WHERE WE CREATE
INTRICATE PAPER ART...
THAT POPS.
JUST LIKE THIS.
IN TODAY'S DIGITAL
AND DISTRACTING WORLD,
THINGS MIGHT BECOME
MORE IMPERSONAL.
BUT A LOVEPOP IS UNIQUE
BECAUSE IT'S UNEXPECTED.
IT'S TANGIBLE.
THE REACTION WE'VE GOTTEN
HAS BEEN SO POSITIVE
AND SO EMOTIONAL
THAT WE REALIZE WE'RE TAPPING
INTO SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER --
THE HUMAN NEED
TO CONNECT.
SO, SHARKS,
HELP US SPREAD THE LOVE.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A COUPLE SPECIAL-EDITION CARDS
FOR YOU GUYS
HERE TODAY.
GOOD. I WOULDN'T EXPECT
ANYTHING LESS.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT.
HERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
LORI.
THANK YOU.
OH, WOW.
THAT IS SO COOL.
OH, OH, OH, OH,
OH, OH, OH, OH, OH!
I LOVE IT!
[ BOTH CHUCKLE ]
Corcoran:
HOW UNEXPECTED. IT IS.
Herjavec:
YOURS IS SHOPPING?
Greiner:
I LOVE IT, YEAH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
O'Leary:
SHOP TILL YOU DROP.
WHAT'S YOURS,
BARBARA?
REAL ESTATE, OF COURSE,
BUT HIS IS MONEY.
YEAH,
HIS IS COOL.
ABSOLUTELY.
Cuban:
YEAH, I LIKE HIS.
[ VOCALIZES ]
Corcoran:
OH, MY, MY, MY.
Greiner: WHAT'S YOURS,
MARK BASKETBALL?
IT'S SHOCKING.
Greiner: SHOCKING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Herjavec:
LOOK HOW INTRICATE IT IS.
O'Leary: SO, TELL US ABOUT
THE BUSINESS MODEL.
YOU HANDCRAFTING
EACH OF THESE?
HOW ELSE
WOULD I FIND YOU?
ARE YOU ONLINE SELLING THEM
OR AT STORES?
YEAH, SO, LET'S -- LET'S BREAK
IT APART INTO TWO QUESTIONS.
SO, THE ONE IS,
WHAT'S THE BUSINESS MODEL?
HOW ARE WE SELLING THESE? AND
ONE IS, HOW DO WE MANUFACTURE?
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA,
WOMBI.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
WOMBI, I LOVE HOW
YOU'RE CONTROLLING THE SHARKS.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, WE'LL START
WITH THE FIRST ONE,
WHICH IS,
HOW DO WE SELL THEM?
SO, WE HAVE FOUR KIOSKS
IN BOSTON.
SO --
IN BOSTON?
IN BOSTON.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S HOMETOWN.
EXACTLY.
SO,
OUR STRATEGY IS KIOSKS,
AND THAT'S WHERE
WE MEET THE CUSTOMER.
THAT'S WHERE THEY HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE,
OPENING THE CARDS,
WHAT YOU JUST EXPERIENCED,
THEN THOSE CUSTOMERS COME ONLINE
INTO THE LOVEPOP ECOSYSTEM,
WHERE WE OFFER
ADDITIONAL SERVICES
LIKE SEND A SURPRISE,
WHERE WE'LL ACTUALLY HAND-WRITE
A NOTE IN THE CARD AND MAIL IT.
OKAY,
WHAT DOES THAT COST?
$8 TO $13 A CARD.
WHOA.
AND IF YOU CHOOSE
TO SEND A SURPRISE OPTION,
IT'S FIVE
MORE DOLLARS.
ARE YOU GUYS ARTISTS?
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
SO, WE'VE ACTUALLY
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR 10 YEARS.
WE WENT TO UNDERGRAD
SHIP-DESIGN SCHOOL TOGETHER.
REALLY?
WOW.
I WENT TO LOUISIANA AND ACTUALLY
DESIGNED SHIPS FOR FOUR YEARS.
HE WENT OFF.
HE GOT A MASTER'S AT M.I.T.
WE ACTUALLY MET BACK UP
IN BUSINESS SCHOOL.
WE GRADUATED FROM HARVARD
BUSINESS SCHOOL THREE WEEKS AGO.
HARVARD?
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU GUYS
ARE HARVARD GRADS?
SO, HOW'D YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
Rose:
SO, WE WERE TRAVELING IN ASIA,
AND WE CAME ACROSS THIS ART FORM
OF SLICEFORM KIRIGAMI.
YEAH.
Rose:
AND WE FELL IN LOVE.
WE WERE JUST LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
THE POSSIBILITIES ARE ENDLESS."
SO, WE CAME BACK.
WE STARTED DESIGNING CARDS.
WE STARTED SELLING CARDS
TO PEOPLE.
Herjavec: JOHN, YOU JUST
GRADUATED THREE WEEKS AGO.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN
RUNNING THE BUSINESS?
SO, IT'S BEEN A YEAR AND A HALF
ENTIRELY WHILE IN SCHOOL.
AND WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
IN THAT YEAR AND A HALF?
$300,000.
BUT IF IT'S AN ARTISAN BUSINESS
AND YOU GUYS ARE HARVARD GRADS,
DID YOU EVER TEST
PRICE SENSITIVITY?
BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T THIS --
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
YEAH,
WHY WOULDN'T IT BE $129?
WHY ISN'T --
IT'S A PIECE OF ART.
WHY ISN'T IT...
Herjavec: WOW.
...$99?
Greiner:
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
WE WANT THIS TO BE
AN ACCESSIBLE ART FORM.
BUT YOU WANT TO MAKE MONEY,
RIGHT?
SURE, BUT WE DO MAKE MONEY
RIGHT NOW.
WE LASER-CUT
THESE CARDS.
WE DESIGN THEM
IN A COMPUTER --
LITERALLY THE SAME SOFTWARE
THAT I USE TO DESIGN SHIPS --
AND THEN INTRODUCE THEM --
LET'S SAY I SENT YOU
3,000 ORDERS A MONTH.
HOW WOULD YOU
PRODUCE THEM?
WE ACTUALLY OPENED OUR OWN
PRODUCTION FACILITY OVERSEAS.
WE PRODUCE 20,000 CARDS A MONTH
RIGHT NOW,
AND WE'RE
SCALING THAT UP.
AND HOW MANY
DIFFERENT DESIGNS?
WE HAVE ABOUT 100
DIFFERENT DESIGNS RIGHT NOW.
WOW.
Herjavec:
LET'S TAKE A SINGLE KIOSK
AND EXTRAPOLATE
OVER A 12-MONTH WORKING PERIOD.
YEAH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE REVENUE WILL BE?
SO, IT'LL BE
ABOUT $240,000.
PER KIOSK?
PER KIOSK.
AND WHAT WOULD BE THE PROFIT
ON THAT?
IT'S GONNA BE
ABOUT $40,000.
AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF A KIOSK PERSON
GOES TO THE WEBSITE
AND BUYS MORE PRODUCT?
SO, WE TESTED THIS
FOR A MONTH AND A HALF,
AND WE HAD 34 PEOPLE COME ONLINE
AND BUY.
THAT'S NOT A LOT,
ACTUALLY.
Cuban:
YEAH, IT'S NOT.
Greiner: NO.
YEAH, WE BELIEVE IN THE KIOSK
MODEL AS A MARKETING VEHICLE.
WHY? WHY?
WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S PROFITABLE.
SO, WE ARE
ATTRACTING CUSTOMERS PROFITABLY,
AND OUR FOCUS
IS ON BUILDING THE BRAND
AND THEN TAKING
THAT COMMUNITY ONLINE,
AND THAT IS THE --
WELL, ACTUALLY, YOUR FOCUS
IS ON BUILDING A CUSTOMER BASE.
THAT, IN TURN, CREATES A BRAND
FOR YOU THROUGH THEIR AWARENESS.
AND --
SO, WHAT IS THE CAPITAL COST
FOR EACH KIOSK?
IT TAKES AROUND $20,000 FLAT
TO OPEN A KIOSK.
CAN I TELL YOU WHAT I DON'T LIKE
ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS,
QUITE HONESTLY?
YEAH.
AT FIRST, WHEN YOU STARTED
TALKING, I GOT ALL EXCITED.
I THOUGHT, "OH, MAYBE THIS IS
MY NEXT COUSINS MAINE LOBSTER."
TWO GUYS RUNNING A SHOP
ARE PRETTY HAPPY MAKING
$200,000 A MONTH ON ONE TRUCK.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU
AND THEM IS, THEY'RE NOT FANCY,
AND I KIND OF LIKE THAT.
THEY WANTED TO GET EVERYTHING
PERFECTLY IN ORDER
BEFORE THEY EVEN BOUGHT
THEIR SECOND COMPANY TRUCK.
THE CARDS -- THEY'RE NICE,
BUT I'VE SEEN POP-UP CARDS
IN EVERY FANCY STORE
I'VE GONE TO.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE THERE?
YOUR LITTLE KIOSK IDEA --
IT'S A SMART IDEA,
BUT I'M TELLING YOU,
IT'S TOO MUCH, TOO FAST,
TOO FANCY
THAT I MISTRUST IT.
AND I'VE INVESTED
IN BUSINESSES LIKE THAT,
AND I ALWAYS LOSE MY SHIRT,
SO, SADLY, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL,
BEAUTIFUL CARDS,
AND I THINK
THAT PEOPLE WILL LOVE IT.
BUT I CAN'T SEE YOUR VALUATION
RIGHT NOW, $300,000 FOR 10%.
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU,
LORI.
I HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESSES
THAT ARE IN THIS SPACE ONLINE
THAT ARE INVOLVED
AROUND MARRIAGE AND ENGAGEMENT
AND TIMES THAT PEOPLE
EMOTIONALLY ARE WILLING
TO SPEND A LOT
ON ARTISAN ITEMS LIKE THIS.
LET ME
SHOW YOU SOMETHING,
BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'LL FIND IT INTERESTING.
♪♪
FOR YOUR
WEDDING CUSTOMERS.
YEAH,
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Greiner:
OH, THAT'S PRETTY.
Cuban: OH, WOW.
IT'S SPECTACULAR,
AND I HAVE SO MANY CUSTOMERS
THAT WOULD BUY THIS.
AND THE THING THAT I LOVE
ABOUT THOSE CUSTOMERS --
THEY DON'T CARE
WHAT IT COSTS.
WHAT IS THE PRICE OF THIS
AT 100 AT A TIME?
SO, WE'VE SOLD THOSE PACKAGES
FOR BETWEEN $2,000 AND $3,000.
FOR HOW MANY?
100 TO 200.
AND OUR MINIMUMS
ARE ACTUALLY PRETTY LOW.
GUYS, THE WAY I UNDERSTAND
YOUR MODEL IS,
IT'S A GET-WIDE --
AS OPPOSED TO GET-TALL -- MODEL,
WHERE YOU WANT TO GET
AS MANY LOCATIONS AS YOU CAN,
BUT MALLS WITH TRAFFIC --
THOSE RENTS ARE GOING UP,
AND THOSE KIOSK SPACES ARE GONNA
GET MORE AND MORE EXPENSIVE.
I THINK
YOU CAN DO IT.
I JUST DON'T THINK
YOU CAN BE BIG ENOUGH
BECAUSE OF THE RISKS
WITHIN THE REAL-ESTATE INDUSTRY,
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU,
MARK.
OKAY.
♪♪
I SEE THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE A FANATICAL CULTURE
AROUND SERVICE
AND YOUR CUSTOMERS.
EXECUTION
IS A LITTLE BIT QUESTIONABLE
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T DONE
ENOUGH OF IT ON SCALE.
♪♪
BUT I'LL MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
♪♪
$300,000...FOR 20%.
YOU WANT A PARTNER ON THAT,
ROBERT?
♪♪
I HAVE
A LOT OF CUSTOMERS HERE.
♪♪
I DON'T THINK IT'S BIG ENOUGH
FOR ME TO PARTNER ON IT, KEVIN.
I THINK YOU WANT TO TAKE IT
TO A DIFFERENT ROUTE.
ALL RIGHT, I'LL MAKE -- I'LL
MAKE THE SAME OFFER EXACTLY.
♪♪
NO PARTNER.
AND I BRING
A PRETTY BIG DATABASE.
I THINK I CAN BRING
A LOT OF CUSTOMERS TO YOU.
♪♪
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
WOMBI AND JOHN
HAVE TWO EQUAL OFFERS
FROM ROBERT AND KEVIN FOR THEIR
GREETING-CARD COMPANY, LOVEPOP.
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS NOW
ALL OF A SUDDEN --
ROBERT'S,
WHICH IS $300,000 AT 20%,
AND YOU HAVE KEVIN'S,
WHICH IS EQUAL.
I THINK I CAN BRING
A LOT OF CUSTOMERS TO YOU.
YEAH, I THINK YOU GOT TO
BUILD IT TO RETAIL PRESENCE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
FIRST, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THOSE OFFERS.
UH, WE DO BELIEVE THAT OUR
VALUATION IS FAIR AT $3 MILLION.
YOU'VE OFFERED US
A $1.5-MILLION VALUATION.
UM...
ALL RIGHT, WOMBI,
I'LL MEET YOU IN THE MIDDLE --
$300,000 FOR 15%.
♪♪
I'LL MAKE
THE SAME OFFER.
♪♪
WELL,
THERE YOU GO AGAIN.
NOW YOU HAVE TWO SHARKS
WITH THE SAME OFFER.
I JUST SEE
TOO MUCH SYNERGY
WITH MY OTHER COMPANIES
IN THIS SPACE.
WELL,
I SEE THE RETAIL PRESENCE.
I LOVED THE IDEA
OF THE KIOSK MODEL.
YOU GOT TO BUILD IT
TO CUSTOMERS.
THAT'LL GET YOU THE BRAND.
AND, BY THE WAY, I'M IN BOSTON,
SO JUST THROWING THAT IN THERE.
BY THE WAY, I WAS JUST
ON A CRUISE IN BOSTON.
WHO CARES?!
♪♪
YEAH.
OKAY.
♪♪
THANK YOU BOTH
FOR YOUR OFFERS.
WE ARE REALLY EXCITED
TO MAKE A DEAL...
♪♪
...WITH MR. WONDERFUL.
[ SIGHS ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A HEART INSIDE.
SOMEWHERE.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
AND YOU'RE
IN BOSTON.
WE LOVE
THE WEDDING CONNECTIONS.
YEAH,
IT'S PHENOMENAL.
O'Leary:
WE MAKE A KILLING WITH THIS.
IT'S GREAT.
NICE JOB.
IT'S COOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S RISK.
GOODBYE, BOYS.
Greiner:
BYE. CONGRATULATIONS.
Wise: WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THE VALUE
THAT MR. WONDERFUL'S
GONNA BRING.
Rose:
HE'S A PHENOMENAL BUSINESS MIND,
AND HE UNDERSTANDS
THE WEDDING BUSINESS,
WHICH IS A BIG
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
♪♪
HEY!
WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
HOW YOU DOING?
WHAT'S GOING ON,
MAN?
John: TODAY,
I'M IN THE HOLLYWOOD HILLS,
AND I'M HOSTING
AN ENTREPRENEURS WORKSHOP
FOR FOUR
OF MY "SHARK TANK" COMPANIES.
JOINING ME ARE SUN-STACHES,
MYSELF BELTS, COZY BUGS,
AND BOMBAS SOCKS.
THE FOCUS OF THIS WORKSHOP
IS BUILDING ONLINE SALES
AND SOCIAL-MEDIA PRESENCE,
AND I HAVE A LOT
OF AMAZING THINGS PLANNED.
HEY, DYLAN,
GOOD SEEING YOU, MAN.
I BROUGHT IN A GUEST SPEAKER
TODAY, DYLAN WHITMAN.
HE IS AN EXPERT
IN ONLINE STRATEGIES.
SO, I'M HERE
TO TALK WITH YOU GUYS
ABOUT ACQUISITION OF CUSTOMERS
AND RETENTION OF CUSTOMERS.
Lessor: ONLINE MARKETING
CAN MAKE OR BREAK A COMPANY.
IF WE CAN TAKE COZY BUG
TO THE NEXT LEVEL
BY WHAT WE LEARNED TODAY,
I'M REAL EXCITED TO DO THAT.
Heath: WE ARE ALWAYS ADMITTING
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW,
AND WE CAN ALWAYS LEARN
FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
MAKE IT MORE ABOUT HAVING
A CONVERSATION WITH YOUR FRIENDS
THAN IT IS
ABOUT WALKING DOWN THE STREET
AND TELLING PEOPLE
WHO YOU ARE.
Man: WE REALLY HAVE VERY LITTLE
SOCIAL-MEDIA EXPERIENCE.
THIS HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE
FOR US.
THANK YOU,
MAN.
THANKS A LOT.
John: NOW I THINK IT'S TIME
FOR SOME FUN.
COME ON WITH ME.
HERE'S MY SURPRISE.
I'VE BROUGHT
MY GOOD FRIEND
CELEBRITY CHEF ROCCO DiSPIRITO
HERE.
ALL RIGHT?
I'VE INVITED ROCCO DiSPIRITO
TO ACTUALLY COOK FOR US.
HE'S DONE
A TON OF SALES ONLINE
AND HAS
A HUGE SOCIAL-MEDIA PRESENCE,
AND I KNOW HE'S GOT
A TON OF GREAT ADVICE TO SHARE.
FIRST THING I LEARNED IS THAT
YOU ARE FOLLOWING YOUR FANS,
NOT THEM
FOLLOWING YOU.
YOU HAVE TO ENGAGE THEM
CONSTANTLY.
Goldfarb:
IT'S SUCH A FUN END TO THE DAY
TO EAT AND LEARN AND TALK
WITH ROCCO.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT SURPRISES
ARE IN STORE WITH DAYMOND.
HOPE YOU GUYS
ARE HUNGRY.
YEAH.
John: I HAVE BIG PLANS
FOR THESE COMPANIES,
AND I KNOW THEY'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO PERFORM.
COMBINED SALES
FROM ALL FOUR OF THESE COMPANIES
ARE $11 MILLION
SINCE "SHARK TANK."
GIVE IT UP
FOR ROCCO.
[ ALL CHEER ]
IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING TIME
WATCHING MY COMPANIES LEARN
AND WORK TOGETHER TODAY,
AND ONCE THEY START TO INTEGRATE
SOME OF THESE ONLINE
AND SOCIAL-MEDIA STRATEGIES,
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE
THEIR BUSINESSES
TO ENTIRELY NEW LEVEL.
THANKS, "D"!
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A SAFER ALTERNATIVE
TO CHEMICAL DEODORANTS.
♪♪
WHOA!
Cuban: OH!
[ CHUCKLES ]
♪♪
GOOD BALANCE.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M JESS.
AND I'M SARAH.
WE'RE ASKING
FOR $50,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10%
OF OUR COMPANY, PiperWai.
THE TOXIC INGREDIENTS
IN CONVENTIONAL DEODORANT
AND ANTIPERSPIRANT
HAVE POTENTIAL LINKS
TO CANCER AND ALZHEIMER'S.
THE PROBLEM IS, WE'VE NEVER
FOUND A NATURAL DEODORANT
THAT ACTUALLY KEEPS BODY ODOR
AT BAY ALL DAY.
THAT'S WHY
WE CREATED PiperWai,
A NEW APPROACH TO DEODORANT
THAT REALLY, TRULY WORKS.
OUR PROPRIETARY BLEND
OF UNIQUE INGREDIENTS
LIKE SUPER-ABSORBENT,
ACTIVATED CHARCOAL
COMPLETELY NEUTRALIZE ODOR
INSTEAD OF JUST COVERING IT UP.
THIS IS OUR FRIEND, HEALTH
AND FITNESS GURU NOELLE ELLIE.
WHEN NOELLE
WOKE UP THIS MORNING,
SHE APPLIED PiperWai,
WENT ON A FIVE-MILE RUN,
AND HAS BEEN WORKING OUT
ON THAT MAT EVER SINCE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
SHARKS, IN A MOMENT,
WHEN NOELLE HANDS OUT SAMPLES,
WE INVITE YOU TO SMELL
FOR YOURSELF JUST HOW WELL...
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, NO!
...PiperWai KEEPS NOELLE
FEELING FRESH AND DRY ALL DAY.
O'Leary:
TO SNIFF THE NOELLE?
OH, NO.
Herjavec: USUALLY, WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO SNIFF THE MODELS.
O'Leary:
IT'S A SCRATCH-AND-SNIFF.
TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT NATURAL DEODORANT...
DOESN'T HAVE TO STINK.
♪♪
I AM NOT
GONNA SMELL HER ARMPIT.
IS IT
YOUR ARMPIT?
IT IS
MY ARMPIT.
ALL RIGHT,
I DON'T CARE.
[ SNIFFS ]
IT'S FINE.
IT'S FINE,
RIGHT?
Herjavec:
YOU DID NOT DO THAT.
IT'S FINE.
I DID DO IT.
I HAD MY OFFICIAL TESTER
CHECK IT OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
WE'LL TRUST LORI.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
SHE SMELLED GOOD.
I TOTALLY
BELIEVE LORI.
Greiner:
OH, IT'S INTERESTING.
IT'S LIKE
A CHARCOAL-GRAY COLOR.
MM-HMM.
IT'S A VERY STRONG
SMELL.
IT -- IT'S OUR PROPRIETARY BLEND
OF ESSENTIAL OILS
THAT CONTAIN
ANTI-MICROBIAL PROPERTIES,
WHICH ACTUALLY HELP IN
THE ODOR-NEUTRALIZING PROCESS.
SO, THE REASON
WE SMELL BAD IS,
THE SWEAT THAT COMES OUT OF YOUR
ARMPITS IS ACTUALLY ODORLESS,
BUT IT STARTS TO STINK WHEN
THE NATURALLY OCCURRING BACTERIA
ON YOUR SKIN
GETS TO IT.
PiperWai WORKS
BY NEUTRALIZING ODOR.
IT CREATES
A pH-BALANCE ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THE ODOR-CAUSING BACTERIA
CAN'T THRIVE,
SO YOUR SWEAT
REMAINS ODORLESS.
Corcoran: WHY PASTE?
MOST PEOPLE
DON'T PUT ON DEODORANT
IN THE FORM
OF A PASTE.
EXACTLY.
AND IT ALSO KILLS
THE MEN'S MARKET.
YES, SO, OUR PRODUCT
IS PERFECT.
IT WORKS BETTER THAN
ANY OTHER NATURAL DEODORANT.
PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN UP
THEIR CLINICAL-STRENGTH
ANTIPERSPIRANT FOR THIS,
AND IT'S HEALTHY
AND GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
DO PREFER IT IN A STICK.
A MAJOR REASON WHY WE'RE HERE IS
TO INTRODUCE A STICK APPLICATOR.
WE HAVE
A PROTOTYPE RIGHT HERE.
Corcoran: SO, THIS IS ALREADY
YESTERDAY'S NEWS.
YOUR CUSTOMER'S
NOT RESPONDING WELL.
THEY WANT IT IN A STICK.
OUR CUSTOMERS
LOVE THIS.
ARE SO PASSIONATE,
THEY EVANGELIZE OUR PRODUCT
TO EVERYONE THEY KNOW.
HOW MUCH DO THEY LOVE IT
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS?
SO, SINCE WE LAUNCHED
18 MONTHS AGO,
WE'VE HAD
$110,000 IN SALES.
NOT BAD.
DID YOU DO
A MARKETING CAMPAIGN?
ALL EARNED MEDIA.
ALL WORD OF MOUTH,
WE GAVE SAMPLES
TO JOURNALISTS AND BLOGGERS
AND FRIENDS AND FAMILY
AND EVERYONE WE KNEW,
AND THEY TOLD EVERYONE THEY KNEW
BECAUSE IT WORKS.
AND WHEN PEOPLE TRY
A NATURAL DEODORANT,
IF IT WORKS,
THEY'RE SUR--.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
$11.99, PLUS SHIPPING
ON OUR WEBSITE.
WHAT IS THE COST?
IT'S $2.74.
HOW DID
YOU DEVELOP IT?
SO, I DECIDED THAT I DIDN'T WANT
TO WEAR ANTIPERSPIRANT ANYMORE,
BUT I COULDN'T FIND ANY
NATURAL DEODORANT THAT WORKED.
SO, I-I SPENT MONTHS
IN MY KITCHEN
RELYING
ON TRIAL AND ERROR,
AND WHEN I FINALLY FOUND
A FORMULA THAT WORKED FOR ME,
I GAVE SOME TO MY BEST FRIEND,
SARAH, OF COURSE,
TO TRY WHEN SHE WENT
ON A SERVICE TRIP TO GUYANA.
IT OBVIOUSLY TOOK SOME
CONVINCING BECAUSE IT'S NATURAL.
IS IT GONNA WORK IN TROPICAL --
A TROPICAL CLIMATE,
AND SHE CALLED ME FROM
AN INTERNET CAFé OVER
FaceTime AND SHE'S LIKE,
"IT'S A MILLION DEGREES HERE,
AND THIS DEODORANT IS WORKING.
YOU HAVE TO SELL THIS."
AND I TOLD HER
I WOULD ONLY SELL IT
IF SHE BECAME
MY BUSINESS PARTNER.
SO, WE DID
SOME MARKET RESEARCH.
WE GAVE SAMPLES
TO FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
WE CONDUCTED SURVEYS
BEFORE EVEN INCORPORATING,
AND THEN WE TURNED IT
INTO A BRAND TOGETHER.
THE CHARCOAL CREAM
THAT YOU PUT ON HERE --
CHARCOAL CREAM -- IS THAT A
TURN-OFF TO ANY OF YOUR BUYERS?
NO.
A LOT OF MAJOR BRANDS ARE GOING
TOWARDS THE CHARCOAL MOVEMENT.
IT'S BECOMING A BIT OF A TREND
IN THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY --
CHARCOAL MASKS,
SOAPS, CREAMS.
IT'S THE "IT" INGREDIENT
RIGHT NOW -- ACTIVATED CHARCOAL.
NEXT QUESTION -- WHAT WOULD YOU
SPEND THE MONEY ON
IF YOU WERE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO GET THE MONEY
HERE IN THE SHARK TANK?
SCALING PRODUCTION AND
INTRODUCING THE STICK APPLICATOR
IN TIME
FOR THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
HAVE YOU DONE
ANY SKIN-SENSITIVITY TESTING?
WE DO PLAN ON DOING
A SENSITIVITY TEST.
THAT IS COSTLY, AND WITH
THE MONEY FROM THE SHARKS,
THAT IS SOMETHING
WE WILL DO IMMEDIATELY.
WHEN IT GOES ON,
DOES IT GOES ON CLEAR?
YES.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANYBODY ELSE
START USING ACTIVATED CHARCOAL
IN THEIR
NATURAL DEODORANTS?
NO, WE ARE THE FIRST
CREAM DEODORANT
TO USE ACTIVATED CHARCOAL.
I THINK
THERE IS A POWDER ON THE MARKET,
BUT IT'S VERY MESSY, AND IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY WORK THAT WELL.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU THINK
WOULD STOP THEM FROM DOING IT?
I MEAN,
OUR COMPETITORS CAN PICK IT UP,
BUT THEY CAN'T TAKE AWAY
THE RESPONSE THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
FROM THE COMMUNITY
WE'VE BUILT AROUND OUR PRODUCT.
YEAH, BUT --
THEY CAN'T TAKE AWAY
THE RESPONSE FROM OUR CUSTOMERS.
LET ME CLEAR
THE FIELD.
MY PROBLEM IS,
YOU COME IN HERE AND SAY,
"WE'RE DIFFERENT
THAN ALL THE BIG GUYS
THAT ARE IN
THE NATURAL SOLUTION.
WE'RE UNIQUE.
WE'RE SPECIAL."
WE ARE.
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
WITH IT BECAUSE --
THE CHEAPEST WORDS
EVER SPOKEN.
Y-YOU HAVE NO MARKET SHARE
IN THIS SPACE.
I MEAN,
LET'S BE REALISTIC.
NOW, ON THE POSITIVE SIDE,
YOU'VE NOT ASKED FOR
A RIDICULOUS
$50-MILLION VALUATION,
WHICH SOME IDIOTS OFTEN
COME IN HERE AND TRY AND DO,
BUT HOW ARE YOU GONNA TURN THIS
INTO A BUSINESS
THAT'S GONNA MAKE MONEY
TO EVEN RETURN MY 50K?
RIGHT NOW,
WE SELL THROUGH OUR WEBSITE.
WE HAVE BEEN SPEAKING
WITH BIG-BOX RETAILERS,
MAJOR eCOMMERCE SITES.
WE WANT
TO CLOSE THOSE DEALS.
99% OF DEODORANTS
ARE PURCHASED IN RETAIL,
NOT ONLINE,
NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO,
YOU HAVE NOTHING PROPRIETARY.
THE GUYS WHO OWN THIS SPACE
ARE REALLY LARGE.
AS A SHARK, I TRY AND STAY
OUT OF THE WAY OF BEHEMOTHS
THAT CAN CRUSH ME IF I START
TO EVEN GET ON THEIR NERVES.
SO, I DON'T THINK ANYTHING
YOU'VE DONE IS HORRIBLE.
IT'S JUST I DON'T SEE
HOW YOU CAN PROTECT THIS
AND BECOME
VERY BIG AT IT.
I CAN JUST SEE YOU
ON THE SIDEWALK.
GONE.
I'M OUT.
CAN I -- CAN I SAY SOMETHING
TO YOU GUYS, SHARKS?
PLEASE DO.
SO, MY MOM
IS A STAGE IV
METASTATIC
BREAST-CANCER SURVIVOR.
AS YOU MAY
OR MAY NOT KNOW,
THE CANCER MARKET IS HUGE,
RIGHT?
WHEN THEY CONTACTED ME,
I WAS VERY SKEPTICAL
BECAUSE I HAVE TRIED ALL --
EVERY ORGANIC,
EVERY ALL-NATURAL DEODORANT.
I'M A VERY ACTIVE PERSON,
AND I TRIED IT, AGAIN,
WITH MY MOM
IN MIND
BECAUSE EVERYTHING THAT GOES ON
HER BODY IS SO IMPORTANT TO ME.
I SPEAK WITH CONVICTION
ABOUT THAT.
I TRIED IT. IT WORKS.
IT WORKS,
BUT HAVING SOMETHING WORK
AND CREATING A BUSINESS
ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
NOT EVERY DEAL
IS FOR EVERY SHARK.
THIS ONE'S NOT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
♪♪
PEOPLE E-MAIL US EVERY DAY
TO SAY THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE HOLY GRAIL
OF NATURAL DEODORANT.
THIS IS LIFE-CHANGING.
THEY CALL OUR PRODUCT
"LIFE-CHANGING."
Cuban:
HOW DO YOU KNOW IT WORKS
OTHER THAN
YOUR OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND ANECDOTAL RESPONSE?
WE HAVE THOUSANDS
OF CUSTOMERS WHO --
THAT'S
ANECDOTAL RESPONSE.
HOW LONG
DOES THIS LAST?
TWO TO THREE MONTHS.
Ribner:
Cuban: AND YOU'VE BEEN SELLING
HOW LONG?
18 MONTHS.
RIGHT,
SO, IN THOSE 18 MONTHS,
JUST ALL
YOUR ORIGINAL CUSTOMERS,
YOU SHOULD BE SELLING
FIVE TIMES MORE
'CAUSE THEY CAME BACK
AND ORDERED MORE.
SO THAT'S TELLING YOU
THAT PEOPLE ARE DROPPING OFF
FOR SOME REASON.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE
MORE SELF-AWARE.
THERE IS NO PERFECT PRODUCT.
THERE'S A REASON WHY PEOPLE
WILL TEST YOURS AND USE OTHERS.
LOOK, GUYS, I'M OUT.
I THINK YOU'RE NOT
BEING SELF-AWARE ENOUGH,
AND I THINK
THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL OF.
Greiner: HOW COULD YOU
BE SELLING MUCH MORE
AND PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT YOU'RE OUT THERE?
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY
BOUGHT IT WOULD BE COMING BACK.
THANK YOU, MARK.
IN 18 MONTHS,
THAT'S 6 TIMES, 7 TIMES
THEY'D COME BACK
AND BUY, RIGHT?
THEY ARE COMING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MARK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Herjavec: BARBARA,
ARE YOU STILL IN?
Edelstein:
HI, BARBARA.
JESS,
I TOTALLY BELIEVE YOU.
THANK YOU.
I-I SEE A WOMAN THERE, STANDING
THERE -- TOTALLY CREDIBLE.
I BELIEVE YOU, TOO,
AND I THINK YOU'RE NATURAL-BORN
PARTNERS -- GREAT START.
SO FAR
AS CLINICAL TESTS GO,
YOU KNOW WHAT THE POOR MAN'S
VERSION OF A CLINICAL TEST IS?
A CUSTOMER ENDORSEMENT.
THE BEST THING
IS TO COME OUT OF THE GATE,
SEE HOW PEOPLE RESPOND TO IT,
IMPROVE YOUR PRODUCT,
GET FEEDBACK,
MAKE CHANGES.
THAT'S WHAT EVERY BUSINESS DOES
WHEN IT'S BIRTHING ITSELF.
NEXT, I LOVE THE WAY
YOU STOOD YOUR GROUND.
YOU HAVEN'T WAVERED ONE BIT
IN BELIEVING IN YOUR PRODUCT,
SO I BELIEVE YOU.
CAN I HAVE
ANOTHER SHOT AT THEM?
NO,
YOU CAN'T.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND LAST,
I'M OFFERING YOU $50,000,
BUT I WANT TO BE
A THIRD PARTNER -- 33%.
Herjavec: OH. WOW.
Corcoran:
AND THE REASON I'M BEING GREEDY
IS BECAUSE
I'LL WORK WITH YOU ON IT.
Greiner:
SO, ANYWAY...
I ALSO HAPPEN TO BE
A BIT OF A HEALTH NUT.
Greiner: I HAVE BEEN LOOKING
FOR A DEODORANT
THAT WOULD WORK
THAT DOESN'T HAVE...
PASS LORI MY DEODORANT.
SHE CAN HAVE MINE. GO AHEAD.
...ALUMINUM OR ANYTHING ELSE
IN IT FOR A LONG TIME.
I HAVE TRIED
EVERY SINGLE BRAND OUT THERE.
NONE OF THEM WORK,
JUST LIKE WHAT YOU SAID.
I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
THE $50,000.
BUT I WANT 35%.
O'Leary: OOH!
WHY?
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE, LORI?
Herjavec: ARE YOU JUST, LIKE,
DIGGING AT BARBARA?
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
JESS AND SARAH
HAVE TWO OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FROM BARBARA AND LORI,
BUT BOTH WANT A MUCH BIGGER
STAKE THAN THE 10%
THEY WERE OFFERING
IN THEIR NATURAL
DEODORANT COMPANY, PiperWai.
I WANT 35%.
O'Leary: OOH!
Corcoran: WHY?
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE, LORI?
ARE YOU JUST, LIKE,
DIGGING AT BARBARA?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
Greiner: YOU NEED A LOT OF HELP.
THERE'S A LOT TO GO THROUGH.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAND
THE CONTROL OF YOUR BUSINESS
OVER TO ANYONE.
I'M REALLY GREAT
TO WORK WITH.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY'RE EVEN
AS TALENTED AS LORI.
I WORK
IN A DEMOCRACY.
YOU WANT
TO HAVE EQUAL SAY...
ALL MY ENTREPRENEURS --
...IN THE BUSINESS
THAT YOU BIRTH.
I DON'T -- I DON'T FEEL THAT
I NEED TO SELL MYSELF.
I KNOW WHAT I DO
IN ALL THE BRANDS I'VE BUILT.
SHE JUST WANTS
TO TAKE CONTROL.
I'M VERY DEMOCRATIC.
I TALK WITH MY ENTREPRENEURS
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
I DON'T
PULL A PLUG ON THEM
OR MAKE A DECISION THAT
WE'RE NOT ALL ON BOARD WITH.
♪♪
LADIES,
YOU HAVE TWO GREAT OFFERS.
WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO?
[ INHALES DEEPLY ]
LORI, WILL YOU GO DOWN
TO 25% FOR $50,000?
♪♪
WOW.
GUYS, I WOULD HAVE TO REALLY
GIVE YOU A LOT OF TIME
AND ATTENTION PERSONALLY.
MY ENTREPRENEURS
GET ME.
I'M ON THE PHONE
WITH THEM.
I'M CALLING THE BUYERS.
I'M DOING THE PACKAGING.
I'M WORKING WITH THEM
HAND IN HAND.
SHE'S A GREAT PARTNER.
BUT I CAN'T HELP YOU AND REALLY
TAKE OVER AND MAKE THIS WORK
AND GIVE YOU
ALL OF THAT DEDICATION FOR 25%.
BARBARA,
WOULD YOU GO DOWN TO 25%?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
O'Leary: WHOA!
♪♪
WE'RE BOTH
IN MANHATTAN.
IT'D BE
A GREAT PARTNERSHIP.
IT'S -- YOU KNOW, WE OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIAL HERE...
SHE SAID SHE'S STICKING.
Ribner: ...AND WE ALL HAVE A
VERY SIMILAR BACKGROUND TO YOU.
I USED TO FLIP REAL ESTATE
IN MANHATTAN.
JESS IS A REALTOR
PART-TIME.
SHE'S WILLING TO GIVE THAT UP
FOR THE COMPANY.
WE'RE VERY SMART.
LIKE, WE KNOW HOW --
WE CAN DEAL WITH A LOT OF THE
MINOR ISSUES IN THE BUSINESS.
WE DON'T NEED
COMPLETE OVERSIGHT. WE --
Corcoran:
I DON'T MISTRUST YOU AT ALL.
YEAH.
I THINK --
NOT AT ALL.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO GO DOWN TO 25%?
YES,
I WILL.
WHAT?!
DEAL.
♪♪
Greiner:
CONGRATS, BARB.
SORRY, LORI.
NO, I WASN'T -- I'M HAPPY
FOR YOU, AND I'M HAPPY FOR THEM.
O'Leary: THAT'S GREAT.
[ ALL SQUEALING ]
STOP THE MADNESS.
GET OUT
OF THE ROOM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M HAPPY
YOU STOOD UP FOR YOURSELVES.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU.
LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU.
Corcoran: I'M SORRY.
I JUST HAD TO DO IT.
NO,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I JUST HAD A --
BARBARA, WHY DID YOU DO IT? YOU
SAID YOU WEREN'T GONNA GO DOWN.
Corcoran: BECAUSE I-I WANTED
TO BEAT HER. THAT'S WHY.
I DID IT PURELY OUT OF MY GUT
'CAUSE I WANTED TO BEAT LORI,
AND THAT'S
THE GOD'S HONEST TRUTH.
YOU ARE
A VICIOUS TACTICIAN.
BARB, THAT'S NOT WHY YOU SHOULD
MAKE A BUSINESS DECISION,
[Laughing]
JUST TO BEAT SOMEONE ELSE.
I'VE MADE SOME REALLY GREAT
BUSINESS DECISIONS
PURELY OUT OF MY GUT,
WITH A DESIRE TO WIN
WITH NO RHYME OR REASON,
AND THIS WAS ONE OF THEM.
WELL, LISTEN --
BARBARA,
I'M SO EXCITED FOR YOU.
WE BUILT THIS BABY
FROM NOTHING,
AND WE TURNED IT
INTO A BUSINESS.
AND NOW WE HAVE BARBARA CORCORAN
AS A PARTNER.
AND AT THE LAST MINUTE, WE
THOUGHT IT WASN'T GONNA HAPPEN,
AND IT DID.
AND WE ARE SO,
SO HAPPY WITH THE OUTCOME.